Valley wrote in a long post basically
one drain she's basically worried about
that her store is going to be on there
forever and then you're gonna be up
there we wouldn't look at it you know no
way to take it down how do you kind of
get over that fear of being so public
and open that your story is there
forever from Valerie well I think
Valerie's it's a valid element once you
post something on on the internet it is
there forever so just need to be I think
thoughtful and careful about what you
want to post and something you know it's
almost cancer yourself and visualize
yourself in the future and if you came
back and read what you've written today
would you feel proud of it I think it's
really important to be authentic the
other thing I'd say is you know again in
this world a profession that we all live
in you know people the authentic people
have vulnerabilities and they share
their vulnerabilities and I think you
know in terms of telling your stories
riya gehen emotionally humans connect to
people who show vulnerabilities people
who you know like superman and
superwoman who are perfect you know they
kind of repel people people who show
that vulnerability draw people towards
them and especially if you're connecting
the heart and the head you know you
connect the emotion you bring people
with you so I'd be advocate a massive
advocate for sharing your story turn
your vulnerability and be really clear
about how you can help other people I
like you who've got a product or
services neither you can provide I think
one of the hardest parts of sharing your
story is worrying about being judged and
being ashamed of certain parts of your
story right let back to one of the
people's questions about overeating now
you have to you know admit that you're
an overeater and share all the deep
things that you get stressed out over
and that's what causes overeating like
that's the juice that's going to connect
me to your story really deeply right
like if your parents got divorced and
you know mistreated you or whatever it
was like if that's what led you to that
moment that's what connects with me but
it's also the hard
it's like deepest moment that you have
to share and expose and it's having the
courage to do that and yes some people
will judge you you know if nobody is
judging you there's no uh if there's no
fear then it's you've lived it so safe
you've written something so safe that
it's not impacting anybody so some
people will judge you that's okay and
you are the champion of truth for your
people right like you started this
business your visionary you're an
entrepreneur you're leading the way in
some paths and people who've lived that
same story or going through the same
problems that you went through before
they want to rally around you and
they'll do that by understanding your
story and so it's a to see this point
about being vulnerable and being open
that's where that's where the real juice
is that's that's the heart of it if you
gloss over it then the story won't have
the impact and so part of telling your
story is being prepared for a little bit
of a judgment but for the most part
every time I put something up it's it's
95 99 percent positive um so just like
as you get bigger you're gonna get
haters it means you're doing something
right means you're doing something
important yeah as you get most
successful you'll get more critics the
other day I was we were a massage
foundation event last week up in the
north of England we had 75 kids from
disadvantaged backgrounds between about
11 and 25 and the old ethos of them is
they came in to sort of do pictures and
and these kids just are ah they were so
inspiring because they told their story
that was so authentic there just to
Evans point they told about their own
personal story the tragedies that
overcome all the difficulties they had
and honestly you just could you could
drop a pin in that room and like I was
leaning forward I just wanted to know
more about these kids and their story so
I think you've got to be honest you've
got to be open you've gotta have that
sense of vulnerability that's relevant
to your story
because the reality is again people are
people as humans and people are
compassionate people want to build by
awesome products from entrepreneurs like
on this I you know Google how now that
are really good to meet the needs
because you've been there you've lived
their anger or the gap in the market
you've identified there and you've
connected your story to the community
you've made that connection and I think
very much part of that Valerie's is your
personality and you want to bring it out